susis lieblings käse kommt unter die
räder
er hat keine chance mehr auszuweichen
und ist sofort tot
wenn man kann als länger verfolgt der
weiß dass ich eine große leidenschaft
habe und diese leidenschaft ist mein
interesse für hochwertige fernseh inhalt
aus deutschland ob hilf mir dsds oder
andere großartige videoproduktion ich
würde mir gerne bereit einen blick auf
die sache zu werfen und für euch zu
kommentieren und ja ich habe heute auch
wen zugänglich gebeten mir neues
material eins zu schicken das habe ich
auch gemacht zahlreichen dank dafür und
eine person uns zugeschickt da da muss
man sich allein beim titel schon
festhalten ich habe eigentlich den namen
der person die man das geschickt hat
aber wenn du das hier siehst dann
kommentierte dem video und ich bin ich
an und ich könnte auf jeden fall auch
den augen der leute der titel ist schon
einfach es ist schon zu viel für die
welt das video heißt nämlich best auch
susanne die kesel queen
ok also leute die qualität von diesem
video ist lange nicht so top aber es
gibt keine bessere version auf youtube
ist das hat mir nicht böse bin susanne
denn nach 45 jahre alt und ich liebe
käse einfach über alles
okay gut ja also das ist ein etwas
spezieller aussage hätte ich jetzt in
der branche erwarte man vom des videos
aber jedem das seine
jeder hat kann seine eigenen hobbys
haben ob es jetzt fußball reiten ballett
oder käse ist das ja prinzipiell erst
mal nichts schlechtes und wir sehen auch
beim geneigten blick in die untere
rechte bild ecke dass das wieder eine
rtl2 produktion ist es eher t20 einfach
ein toller fernsehsender und das
schlimmste für mich jetzt ist im moment
dass ich den these im moment gar nicht
bezahlen kann
die ah das ist eine situation nicht mir
persönlich jetzt in der art und weise
noch nicht selbst begegnet ist aber
vielleicht habe ich einfach keine ahnung
was gut ist kommt ich bin jetzt nicht um
weil ich schon so spät was ist denn du
weißt dass ihr sohn der der rechts erst
schauen wir zu glas wie die
parfümeriekette und erscheint aktuelle
in akuter geldnot zu sein könnte es
daran liegen dass seine mutter das ganze
geld für käse ausgegeben hat angesichts
der bisherigen sachlage würde ich sagen
ja
die schule die macht die klassen vater
muss auch gucken wir sind hier der das
bezieht sich ja klar ist jeder alles
bezahlen von douglas natürlich sicher da
wo ich die schule
ok ja ich glaube elternsein funktioniert
nicht so recht ob die frau dann links
ist sowieso ihre kindergärtnerin oder im
iso nanny die auf die kinder aufpasst
und der rechtssache die jetzt schon
legendäre susanne die das mit der schule
noch nicht so ganz verstanden hat also
ich persönlich hab viele klassenfahrten
gemacht und bin von der einer
klassenfahrt ausgeschlossen worden wegen
nicht optimalen verhalten aber dass an
der geschichte so oder so auf jeden fall
er hat die schule noch nie in die
klassenfahrt bezahlt in meiner welt
priska rios im moment aber nicht
gleichzeitig lachen und weinen will also
ja analysiert wir erst mal die situation
das ist ein best of also wir sehen sie
aneinander geschnitten
ein scheinbar sicher sein einen
bollerwagen voll käse besorgt aus diesen
bollerwagen ist ein babybett
herausgefallen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
an dieser stelle alle pbb susis
lieblings käse kommt unter die räder
er hat keine chance mehr auszuweichen
und ist sofort
da ja der kästen keine chance aus weil
ich hab mich schon mal sind mitten in
der sache ausreichend will dass wir das
geld ja projekt baby wäre der gau das
stück parmesan vor sich auf dem tisch
wir wollten wir sahen so bleiben oder
das baby war essen und der hätte das
scheiß teil war ich einfach raus
das ist natürlich nicht der sinn der
sache deswegen kann käse auch
normalerweise nicht ausweichen bisschen
über dramatisch dargestellt von rtl2 an
der stelle ein pizza aber ich muss auch
sagen egal was andere so ist dichter und
es ist schon jetzt tatsächlich mal rtl2
konnte der mitte hält gut tut was ich
habe nicht nicht übersprungen und der
sohn das war einfach das nächste was
nach dem ist wigan dimap gespielt haben
kam war einfach tot tot ist es scheinbar
tot konnte nicht mehr ausweichen
ich weiß war es billiger wie groß ist
der fakt dass sich aus den kriegs
schocker zu händen weil das schon drei
kilo vive la vie naja für die geneigten
käseliebhaber unter uns ist das
vielleicht das richtige
[Musik]
was mache ich hier gerade leute schauen
wir also angerichtet
alter die guardian was haben die
verkehrte vorräte in diesem bollerwagen
deshalb noch mal so einen laib einfach
so der liegt locker sechs kilo
also ich wirklich nicht sagen leute und
ich will auch niemand für seine
persönlichen vorlieben verurteilen aber
wenn er jemanden trifft der einen sechs
kilo laut käser im bollerwagen hinter
sich herzlich ganz mit rechten dingen
zugehen die käse in thusis den ist
fassungslos was für eine welt wird
unschuldiger käse am hellichten tag
überfahren
ich versuche mir doch zu verstehen was
ist das für ein beitrag das ist der
ganze weitergabe von dem parodie oder
ist es einfach so schlecht gespielt aber
bewusst lustig gemacht aber es ist keine
comedy sendung oder es ist doch eine
comedy sendung ich weil es für mich so
recht ein begräbnis ist das mindeste was
sie jetzt noch tun
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie begräbt den käse möchte von allen
guten geistern verlassen
aber ganz davon abgesehen läutet man
begräbt nicht im sandkasten ops euer
haustier ist okay so tier nicht mehr
ausweichen konnte
oder gott bewahre ein mensch in der
situation nicht im sandkasten ressorts
gibt friedhöfe einen sandkasten ist
nicht der richtige ort für ein begräbnis
hallo
der käse ist tot ok du kannst einen
toten sind einfach abwaschen und wieder
im kühlschrank packen du kannst ja auch
nicht nur toten menschen einfach nehmen
und keine ahnung abwaschen
dann setzte den wieder auf seinem
bürostuhl ich weiß es nicht leicht damit
umzugehen aber einen unbeliebten körper
einfach zu weich und so gut wie nichts
passiert
es war eigentlich die beste idee
[Musik]
okay das leben als käse für ihn auch
dass man käse quizmaster ist also ich
weiß nicht ob ich noch nicht mehr mit
dem berufsfeld käse queen
auseinandergesetzt also kann man
bestimmt studieren bachelor auf skis
oder so aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
wir als professionelle käse queen so
viele verschiedene aufgaben hat
begräbnisse quizshow leiten den eigenen
kindern den schulausflug nicht bezahlen
dann kann ich verstehen wenn das an den
nerven zehren man auch das eine oder
andere etwas ungewöhnlichere
verhaltensmuster an den tag legt die
erste frage die sich mir stellt warum
hat sie eine beleuchtete sich auf
verschiedene fragen erste frage wie
gesagt warum auch sie eine beleuchtete
brille zweite frage wer wird da gefragt
warum sind die in der krise kurs schon
irgend kontext hat irgendwie weiter
gesehen kann mich aufklären
ach ja und frischkäse reife oder nicht
kein effekt für euch jetzt kommt die
zweite frage
[Musik]
also innerhalb deutschlands kann man die
frage relativ leicht beantworten der
innerhalb deutschlands größte käse
prozent ist nämlich keine molkerei wie
man jetzt denken möchte vielleicht
sondern tatsächlich im fernsehsender und
zwar rtl aus köln
wenn irgend jemand von euch plan hat was
ist mit diesem wortwörtlichen käse auf
sich hat schreibt es gerne in die
kommentare und kernig auch meine
wunderschöne traumreise ins käse land
geht an dieser stelle zu ende und ich
kann euch hier trieben noch eine für
euch vorgeschlagen das video empfiehlt
es gibt eigentlich im käse aber lohnen
sich wahrscheinlich darauf zu klicken
macht's gut wenn du das nächste mal nach
dem größten deutschen käseproduzenten
gefragt werdet müsst ihr besser bescheid